Welcome back to the David Pakman show. It's
great to welcome to the program today. Peter
Pomerantz [inaudible] who is a country
eating editor at the American interest and
director of the arena program at the London
school of economics. He's author most recently
of the book. This is not propaganda adventures
in the war against reality reality as well
as other books, some of which I've previously
recommended to my audience. So it's great
to talk to you, Peter. I appreciate it. Thank
you for the recommendations. Really kind of,
yeah. So to start with, uh, give the audience
a bit of your background, uh, in Russia and
the places you've lived. Cause I think that's
a big part of your insight into what we'll
be talking about.
Sure. I mean, like from a family point of
view, my parents were Soviet dissident. Um,
they ran into trouble with the KGB in the
1970s and ended up being exiled, which was
quite common at the time. And I ended up growing
up in London. Um, then after 2001 off to university,
I went back to Russia and, um, uh, ended up
working in television actually, um, kind of
an entertainment television and making reality
shows and, and, and same with chosen all these
terrible, terrible things. Um, but that gave
me a lot of insights about kind of the development
of the Putin propaganda model. Cause I was
kinda working near the belly of the beast,
maybe from an inside of it, but not far away
from it. And, um, I wrote my first book about
that. I'm trying to define the way that the
Putin regime uses propaganda in this very,
very, you know, pretty original way.
Um, and then of course what's happened since
then is that, you know, the two techniques
that were honed inside of Russia have been
used for foreign influence campaigns. Um,
and my second book kind of looks at kind of
propaganda across the world and how it's changing
and things about why Russia is particularly
adept at play, the contemporary game. And
now I, you know, I run this a little think
tank at the London school of economics, which,
which studies that and thinks about how we
overcome some of the challenges of disinformation
of polarization and the other pathologies
that I'm sure your, your kind of viewers and
listeners are, are more than aware of.
Yeah. So I mean, I guess let's start with
that in the last five to seven years or you
know, in, in, in the last decade maybe. Are
there ways in which what we are seeing in
the West reminds you of the Russian techniques
that were not as visible in the West more
than a decade ago
show? I mean, even even you can go back to
the 1990s and you see these things develop
that I think a lot of it is actually cultural
rather than just technical. I mean, this idea,
this focus on nostalgia rather than an idea
of the future. Um, this kind of post-left
right moments. Um, we kind of post ideological
moments where policies and sort of rational
arguments become much less important than
all politics just becomes about capturing
some sort of feeling. I mean, feelings were
always present politics, but now the feeling
becomes everything. Um, this constant redefinition
of the people in the non people. It's kind
of 21st century version of, of, of populism.
Um, this constant kind of like, you know,
um, mixing of different messages to different
audiences. The, the, the lack of any kind
of coherence, uh, for other political successful
political movements. And perhaps most importantly,
this idea that you can't hold power accountable
with the truth anymore.
This, uh, um, bizarre place we're in where
politicians kind of rebel in lying and, and
even make a thing out of it. Um, and show
complete disdain for factuality in factual
language. Um, all of that was really evident
in, in Russia already in the Monty nineties
for reasons I explore in the book. Um, then
there's also the technical side, the kind
of, uh, the use of, um, you know, uh, the
use of, of troll farms, online mobs and cyber
militias. And that's something that Kremlin's
already playing with in 2010. Um, as a way
to respond to, to, uh, kind of the Democrat
democratic use of the internet. Um, so, so,
so yeah, Raj has been somewhat of a pioneer
in these things. Um, partly because it lost
the cold war by losing the cold war. They
ended up in a place in the 1990s. We're kind
of all old versions of the future of left
and right politics or the death of social
definitions of collapsed. Um, and so political
technologists, that's a Russian term for propagandists
and politicians start experimenting with how
to survive in this kind of, in this new world.
Yeah. So I want to dig into that a little
bit because there are many in the West who
know the techniques, but they don't necessarily
know the Genesis and what catalyze those techniques
to be pioneered in Russia as you're pointing
out. And it's very easy to just say ad they're
just evil or you know, it's conniving Putin
or these very simplistic explanations. So
can you talk a little bit more about what
were the circumstances that led to Russia
being the place where a lot of these techniques
were pioneered?
Well, they as often actually in historically
by, because they lost the cold war. And then
because democratic capitalism kind of collapsed
as any kind of coherent ideology by 1993 in
Russia, sort of absolute disastrous consequences
for reforms. Um, they were kind of left this
back to you. Um, and there was no idea of
the future that so making kind of fact-based
arguments about the future, um, became, became
pointless. Uh, so instead there was a reveling
in nostalgia. Um, and I interview a lot of
these kind of spin doctors were operating
retro in the 1990s. They're like that we couldn't
make any kind of coherent policy arguments
anymore because all the coherent rational
policies were making people unhappy. Uh, so
instead we just focused on uniting people
around a vague feeling, you know, bringing
Russia off its needs, which obviously sort
of anticipates making American great again.
So, so that's kind of the cultural moment.
Um, but also you have this kind of understanding
that look, you can't do, we live in incriminate,
increasingly fractured world and increasingly
fractured environment and, and you win by
retargeting different messages at different
groups. In very honed and specific ways. Um,
and, and you know, in the early two thousands,
which is when I was in Russia, I mean, that
was so remarkable about that version of gluten,
the way you can completely transform for different
audiences. Um, so, you know, it's sell the
far left one version of Buddhism, the far
right, another one. Um, and not even ideologies,
interest groups. Here's your work thing and
here's your thing. And it didn't need to come
together into a coherent whole in a political
ideological sense, but it would already have
to make sense. Um, again, by uniting around
a very big, big that anybody could interpret
their own way.
Um, so, so you know, what we see Russia doing
abroad since then is, you know, he really
finding completely contradictory audiences,
whether it's, um, the far left and written
or the far right in the U S uh, and sort of
like, you know, dragging them in to the Kremlin's,
uh, weapon interests. Um, so, so, you know,
kind of at the technique's home inside the
country have proven very, um, useful abroad,
but, but I wouldn't overestimate Russia's
kind of influenced on things. I mean, in clearly
play, you know, play as sort of a tactical
game. I mean, what, what's much more important
is, is that we're seeing Western countries
and especially America, arrived culturally
at a very similar face. The Russia right through
the 1990s. We can think of many reasons why
all kinds of versions of left and right politics
collapse. Why all versions of the future collapse
for enough people.
Um, 2008 crisis. The sense that people's children
are going to be poor with them. Then we can,
we can talk about many, many factors, um,
but, but in many ways, you know, America culturally,
uh, has arrived to Russia in the early 1990s,
um, maybe not politically, of course, in the
sense of rich institutions or in, you know,
it's court systems and so on and so forth.
I'm kinda talking about like the political
culture. Um, uh, kind of, uh, the, the, uh,
uh, the, the Palm of frost underneath the,
uh, the institutions is melting in a very
similar way.
When you think back to the time where some
of these techniques were, were maybe in, in
their heyday, so to speak, and not to suggest
that they've diminished, but maybe when, when
they were more prevalent in a particular,
uh, way, how did they, or did they affect
the personal and family lives of Russians?
We have sort of a sense, you know, in North
Korea of the way that North Korean propaganda
is woven into the daily lives with the speaker.
You can't turn off with the speeches and sort
of these other ways, but how, how, if at all,
did the daily lives of Russians, uh, change
by virtue of these techniques that started
being used domestically?
And listen, I mean, in that sense, rushers,
not like North Korea, not let the Soviet union
it has. Um, when I was at, it's a little,
had sort of the last vestiges pluralism, um,
but at the end of the day, you can get information
from the West online very, very easily. Um,
there's no kind of like Soviet style or more
Korean self censorship. You can leave the
country. Uh, so that's in so much more open
system. And what the Kremlin did was realized
that look, instead of trying to send to this,
they were flooded with so much information,
information people couldn't find a way through
the smirky world anymore. In this dark, chaotic
world. You turn to strong leaders, uh, to
kind of, uh, to guide you. Um, and they began
to use conspiracy thinking, uh, and cynicism
as a kind of cross eye replacement for ideology.
Uh, conspiracies weren't just a way to sort
of explain the world, but the propaganda pushed
out in nonstop the sense that the truth is
unknowable that we live in this, you know,
dark, dark world where, um, conspiracy is
layered on conspiracy and layered on conspiracy.
And in this confusing world, you can't believe
in anything. Everything is corrupt. Democracy
in the West is rigged. Uh, and you need a
strong Putin to protect you. And you know,
it's remarkable seeing how effective that
is. And we now see that across the world,
uh, in Turkey and you slot in for me, you
can slap. Yeah. And of course in America,
wow. You know, you have a leadership that
maybe they believe in some of the conspiracy
theories, which is really scary, but they
definitely use conspiracy theories, uh, all
the time. Again, to give people a sense of
the truth is unknowable. Um, and that's a
big difference between 21st century propaganda
and 20th century propaganda. It's not trying
to convince people over true, it's trying
to seed so much doubt that people just lose
the will to struggle and live in a political
sense.
Yeah. I've said that it's much more, even
though people like to say that it's like 1984,
it's actually much more like Aldous Huxley's
brave new world in that sense.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I think, I think, I think
there are still lots of learn from all, well
without a doubt, but, but, uh, maybe Huxley
is, the better, uh, is the better died. Um,
but it's, I mean, this is something that the
Kremlin did early and out of a sense of crisis.
Said, like, okay, we can't impose censorship.
What do we do? How do we impose what this
Russian media predictability gotta of course,
white jamming just confused people so much
and make them feel that, uh, you know, they
can't change anything. Cause that's, you know,
that's just the nasty little thing about this
conspiracy thinking. If you live in a world
full of dark conspiracies for the deep States
and full of, you know, endless media plots,
then that means you the little guy can't change
anything. It's wonderfully clever way of demotivating
people and undermining the democratic potential.
Um, the criminal could have turned out of
desperation, you know, and it kind of like,
I had nothing else to work with because imposing
censorship, you know, that really, you know,
total censorship is really hard than anyways.
Um, but I see it now used across the world.
Um, and, and it's used in mature democracies
as well, which is very, very the stuffing,
one of the things that I see a skeptics of
Russian meddling in the U S repeat very often
here in the United States, uh, are sort of
isolated about where the current administration's
actions appear, not to line up cleanly with
Russian interests. And what I feel like is
missing from these analyses is an understanding
of the level of sophistication and nuance
that goes into a lot of these techniques that
are being used by Putin, where it's not about
a, on any particular issue necessarily, um,
getting the immediate alignment on policy,
but it is about what you're talking about
sowing the doubt, destabilizing some of the
main, uh, systems that are used to make policy
in the first place. Um, making people question
whether the democratic system is properly
working as designed. Can you talk a little
bit about the, the level of nuance that is
needed to understand that? Just looking at,
well, Trump bombed Syria, so therefore that,
that's just not deep enough to really understand
the level at which these techniques operate.
Yeah, I mean Trump, I mean, Trump's pulled
out of serious, that's complete alignment
or yes, it's completely reversed. Of course
Russia had already booked, I mean, Russia
already had Obama's kind of game with Syria,
so that, that wasn't, um, I don't think that's
what they were looking at. So, um, look from
what West speculating about what their game
plan was, but we assume given on really the
bits of evidence that we have, that the aim
was to see doubts. So to push up, uh, Trump
as much as they could, assuming Hillary would
win. But then, you know, getting readying
this narrows a bit. It was rigged. You know,
that the system's rigged. That, you know,
Trump lost because the other side cheated.
Um, it's that sowing doubts, which, which
is kind of the metanarrative all the time.
That's the metanarrative that they use at
home.
Basically. The, like, they didn't say that,
that, you know, nobody in Russia claims that
it's a healthy democracy or there's no corrupt,
their argument is, well, the West is just
as corrupted us as us. Yeah. The whole world
is rotten. So, so we assume that was it. You
know, that was the kind of the game plan and
then Trump went and won. Um, and, and well
that was a bit of a, you know, that may have,
that may have, you know, that may have been
a stumping to them as to us. So, um, we don't
know, but look, Trump aligns with the criminal
in a very deep way, um, which is in his deep,
deep cynicism. You know, when Crump Trump,
you know, recently we had transcripts, uh,
from 2016 when Trump still tells the Russians,
look, I don't mind what you did in the U S
because the U S government does the same sort
of thing. That kind of equivalence, um, is,
is the essence of kind of the Putin and T
ideology media. Um,
and the other thing that seems powerful in
that it seems to me is that very often the
conspiratorial ideas do have an element of
truth in the sense that, for example, the
idea that the system is rigged and democracy
may not be functioning as designed. That's
something a lot of people on the American
left have been saying for a long time. But
in different ways than, than became the talking
point after the 2016 election. And that's
probably something that helps these ideas
self perpetuate in society when there is an
element of truth to them. But the details
are going completely awry.
Well all good propaganda does that. I mean
it always mixes truth and fiction or takes
a good idea and then pushes it to sort of
an absurd and destructive conclusion. But
like I think it's quite a simple sort of dividing
line. There is a difference between constructive,
you know, policy suggestions, which should
be based on criticism. That's fine. And that
kind of cynicism which says our democracy
is impossible, full stop, therefore, you know,
every system is rigged, therefore, you know,
we should just leave the world open to two
strong men. And no, all the values are all
universal values that just as charades. So
therefore let's have a zones of influence
where every country makes up their own by
their own system of norms and human rights
are just in there. So I think, I think there's
a difference between, you know, a criticism
that it's meant to strengthen democracy.
And, and, uh, uh, and you can tell that usually
by the, by, by the speech, the nature of the
speech because it invites argument and genuine
debates. Um, you know, there's lots of theories
of democracy. We talk about that. That's the
nature of the conversation that's important.
And this kind of conspiratorial cynicism,
which ends any conversation because it says,
well, everything's regretful. There's nothing
to talk about. So I didn't, I didn't find
it very hard to differentiate between the
two. And I think most people that they think
about it wouldn't find that very hard either.
But, but maybe on a certain kind of momentary
level, um, you can fall for this kind of artsy
nonsense. But I really, I think people do.
I mean, I hope not cause that's so impressive.
To what degree do you see as what's going
on in the UK with Boris Johnson as tracking
some of what is happening in the U S similarities?
Differences.
So this isn't the way I encourage people to
talk about what I'm talking about, which is
a political culture. Propaganda is in the
formation of public opinion. Um, political
rhetoric, which are the things that I'm interested
in. Look, I compare it to art. I mean art
is very similar in the same way that gonna
manifest itself in similar ways in different
countries. So you have, you know, in the turn
of the 20th century, you have modernism in
Russia and the Soviet union, uh, will begin
to say that union, uh, in America and Britain,
um, so you have these common phenomenon breakout
cause that's, that's the tight Geist. Um,
they will manifest themselves in national
idioms, you know, so they're going to be very,
very different in Britain to American cause
at different countries. But without a doubt,
Boris Johnson as someone who had been caught
lying, who lost his job as a journalist because
he lied and that hasn't stopped him succeeding.
He's someone also sort of pedaling nostalgia
nonstop. So there are clear motifs that repeats.
Um, we've moved away. Even Brexton was a move
away from left and right politics, uh, or
central politics, which the week you intend
to marry this to, to pure emotions, targeted
messaging, and a kind of a creation of the
people. You know, it's not a populism isn't
an ideology, it's a strategy is creation of
an idea of the people who are sense of the
people for every election. So that's, that's,
that's a seminar seat. But then there were
million differences. I mean, jumps in and
like Trump is, it's not a, you know, he's
a highly educated man and et cetera, et cetera.
And, and probably a very different kind of
dinner companions to Trump. Um, so there's
huge differences as well. Um, but none of
this, there's some sort of tie guys. I mean,
we see it in the Philippines with detected
with Oban. I mean, it's not a coincidence
that all these people were also men of a certain
age, you know, and there's, there's a lot
of similarities. Um, and my book, I talk a
lot about that language, this obsession with
kind of jokes about human private parts, about,
you know, like dirty jokes. How all of them,
uh, in Belgium, this language and what does
that mean and what does that say about us?
We've been talking, uh, somewhat about, uh,
what is in the book. This is not propaganda
adventures in the war against reality and
about many other things with the books, author
Peter Pomerantz, of who's a contributing editor
at the American interest and also directs
the arena program at LSC.
Peter, so great having you on. I really appreciate
your time. It's my pleasure. Anytime